KOH KIM: I'm part of the Google
Play business development team
here in Mountain View.
I focus on game start-ups
in international markets.
So it's a big world out there.
With Play, you can distribute
in 190-plus countries,
sell in 130-plus markets,
and actually price
in 65 currencies, which
is a pretty big world.
But even with one billion
active Android devices,
only one in four people in the
world own a smartphone today.
Imagine if we connect the
next five billion people.
And that's what
we're planning to do.
So where should I start first?
Localization is hard work.
So it's critical to
choose the right markets
that best fit your game.
So developers are making
money all over the world,
here and abroad, especially
in Korea, Japan, and Taiwan.
But we're growing fast in other
countries around the world,
too, markets like Brazil,
Southeast Asia, Turkey
and Russia provide interesting
opportunities for developers
to expand their
active user base.
Asia is a big market for us, and
users here are very different.
Subway commutes can be an
hour or longer each way.
However, they're able
to constantly connect
to high speed mobile internet
networks during their commutes.
So you can imagine
the type of gaming
that can occur with such
pretty fast connection.
So now that you have an idea of
what the different markets are
like, how can you take advantage
of this growth and the reach?
Make sure you have the
right game for your market.
I'm sure you recognize
some of these games that
are popular in the US, different
visual styles, different types
of genres.
You have puzzles, you have
strategy games, and et cetera.
But we can take
a look at markets
like Japan, Korea, and Taiwan.
It looks quite different.
Role playing and
strategy games focusing
on multi-player and
collection mechanics
are actually very popular.
And it looks a little
bit different, too, just
from the icons alone.
And it gets more interesting in
emerging markets like Brazil,
Russia and Southeast Asia.
For example, cricket is
a popular sport in India.
So of course, a cricket game
would actually be popular.
However, you'll
still recognize some
of these games, which actually
presents immense opportunities
for developers like you.
But not all dragons are
created equal, right?
First impressions count.
And it starts with the icon.
You can choose to
use one icon globally
to reinforce your brand.
Or if you have a character
featured in your icons,
adapt your visual
style to the audience.
Be mindful of your text.
You should actually remember
to make your game title
pronounceable in
that target language.
If not, change it
or simplify it,
like you can see with Ace
Fishing and Candy Crush Saga.
But you can also
localize your screenshots
to your target market.
Seeing something
in their language
tells the players that you
care and that they can actually
understand what's
going on in the game.
And the Asian screenshots are
probably a little bit different
from what you see.
But creating videos is
actually a great idea, too.
It helps users imagine their
game in their own environments.
This Korean commercial
portrays high school students
challenging each other while
on break in between classes.
And make sure you
have the right price.
In US and Europe, players are
used to seeing prices end in 9.
That's not the case in
Asia, where they end in 0.
Luckily, you can customize your
prices right in the Google Play
Developer Console.
But your job isn't over yet.
Now that players
installed your game,
you have to keep them playing.
Asian players consume
a lot more content
than the average
Western players,
sometimes up to
4x the US player.
So push new content and events
to keep your new players
on your toes.
And you can also connect with
players on their channels.
Respond to user feedback
on the Play Store,
enable social features
like Chat and Forums
to allow players to
communicate within your game.
And that's it.
Thanks, all.